what's up guys I'm Tim gettys i'm here
with Alfredo Diaz and we are looking at
halo five card game that's very close to
our heart oh yeah halo halo is probably
the source of our relationship this is
true this is Howard man yeah you know we
played a lot of blood gulch back in the
day a lot a lot of CTF a lot of that and
we also did a lot of the campaign
missions co-op together that would be
our thing back in the day a shot back
then how many some barton's there were
his loss ever back my damn it's like man
there was one and he was awesome who's
the genders a ton of them and their ones
one group is hunting the other group
it's like what's going on the Halo
universe right now and I'm pretty sign
on this i remember back in the day you
you and my boy current would love
reading the books and stuff and all
these other sparklemore each good really
good book Linda she was the sniper was
you guys favor and stop and now here she
is in a game like 10 years later yeah I
can't believe it it's it's really cool i
right like the whole concept of light is
the master chief a traitor like what's
the truth and like you know and you have
another Spartan yeah Spartan Locke who
is like hunting down the chief and
trying to make him pay for the things
he's done it's like what's what's going
on like yeah chief camping being in the
wrong here like I don't know like this
is a story that I want to dive into
right yeah so many times more just like
another halo you know oh here comes the
flood again yeah right now Kurt honest
save the day now it's just like okay
cool like the Covenant are there and
sure there's like the whole guardians
and everything like that but you have
this like core conflict between the most
elite i guess like soldiers and that the
human race has yeah pretty cool yeah it
definitely is man the halo campaigns
have always been something special was
there they're really well designed to ya
get you from place to place and tell
that story now except for the library
level of course no commentary level but
you see this and like this part right
here where they start jumping through
this is man it's intense it's really
cool and I love seeing things like this
where the ship kind of crashes and then
you're in this side crazy thing with a
jetpack it along and doing yet things
all generalities and stuff like later on
you'll see like the Spartan slam you
dash here so it's really cool you're
very mobile now so the
definitely taking advantage of that and
of course you have that cinematic feel
to it just seems like it's on a much
more grand scale now yeah it's
interesting you to see this because you
know you get so used to the halo of old
where it you do have Cortana with you
and you do just the levels would kind of
all feel the same and you kind of get
this thing where everything looks the
same yeah when you are more on earth or
on one of the halos on the outside
everything looks kind of like you brown
and green and stuff then you get into
the Covenant stop it everything is
purple I mean yeah buck from ODST who is
now a Spartan that's awesome play by
Nathan Fillion oh wow yeah so that's
pretty cool I think one of the things
that kind of struck me as I really
awesome is that in the older Halo games
right you'd be master chief and you're
fighting the Covenant so all the fire is
like the firefight is happening between
you and a bunch of other people here
just like there's just stuff like you
have like mini war zones going on
between your squad and the enemy around
you yeah which i think is really sick
yeah it's definitely gonna be
interesting I'm excited to how it goes
so we also we don't have the footage of
this right now but there's the
multiplayer aspect they announced today
yea orsa war zone mmm we have to play we
love it what do you think I thought it
was cool it's it's essentially kind of
big team battle right like I'm huge huge
battles between player versus player but
in them is 12 on 12 right I believe ya
24 total and then so what happens is a
so you have the PvP aspect to it right
and you have your basis to defend you
have basically you can like their base
to take over itself like that and
there's like you essentially kill other
players or you can also kill like the AI
is around for additional points right
and you're essentially trying to gain
the most points etc and like the the
more you do for your team like
everything a little thing contributes to
the score and so like more aspiring to
kill or say you take down like an AI
boss that's around right like one of
their AI bosses or like one just the
standard AI character stuff like that
cool it's all it's like really cool
stuff and it's very interesting I think
it cares more towards like the casual
audience for sure that how did it
compare to like firefight I mean the PBP
aspect other characters being there like
that are not a are controlled hmm so
into cool then definitely very
interesting i'm excited to see this and
i can't wait to play through with you
little co-op action OTAs it's going to
be good
gentlemen this is halo 5 guardians